Does the thought of household budgeting make your palms sweat and your heart race? Did you avoid math classes when you were in school? Or pick a career where you thought you'd never have to encounter numbers? Or maybe you have a child who panics at the mere thought of algebra. Math is essential to our everyday lives, but for people with math anxiety, any tasks involving math can cause dread and fear. Now psychologists are studying where math anxiety comes from,
一想到家庭预算，你就会手心出汗、心跳加速吗？你在学校时曾刻意避开数学课吗？或者选择了一个你以为永远不需要接触数字的职业？或者，你也许有个孩子，仅仅一想到代数就会惊慌失措。数学对我们的日常生活至关重要，但对于患有数学焦虑的人来说，任何涉及数学的任务都会引起恐惧和害怕。现在，心理学家正在研究数学焦虑的根源，
how it affects people's lives and careers, and what interventions can help people overcome it. So how common is math anxiety? When does it usually start? Can you be good at math but still have math anxiety? Are girls more likely to experience it than boys? If you have math anxiety, what can you do to become more comfortable with math? And if you're a parent who see signs of math anxiety in your child, what can you do and where can you go for help? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
它如何影响人们的生活和职业，以及哪些干预措施能帮助人们克服它。那么，数学焦虑有多常见？它通常什么时候开始？你可能擅长数学但仍然有数学焦虑吗？女孩比男孩更有可能经历这种情况吗？如果你有数学焦虑，你能做些什么来对数学感到更自在呢？如果你是一位家长，在孩子身上看到了数学焦虑的迹象，你能做些什么，又可以去哪里寻求帮助？欢迎收听“心理学说话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
My guest today is Dr. Molly Jameson, a professor of psychological sciences at the University of Northern Colorado. She's an educational psychologist who studies math anxiety in both children and adult learners. She's explored the factors that contribute to math anxiety, as well as the relationship between math anxiety and math performance. She also created a developmentally appropriate scale to assess math anxiety in primary grades and has worked on interventions for students and teachers to decrease math anxiety. Dr. Jameson, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me, Kim. Let's start with the basics. How do you recognize and define math anxiety? I know a lot of people think, well, I don't like math or I'm not great at math, but how do you differentiate
我今天的嘉宾是北科罗拉多大学心理科学教授莫莉·詹姆森（Molly Jameson）博士。她是一名教育心理学家，主要研究儿童和成年学习者的数学焦虑。她探讨了导致数学焦虑的因素，以及数学焦虑与数学表现之间的关系。她还创建了一个适合发展阶段的量表，用来评估小学低年级的数学焦虑，并致力于开展旨在减轻学生和教师数学焦虑的干预措施。詹姆森博士，谢谢你今天做客我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我，金。我们从基础开始。你如何识别和定义数学焦虑？我知道很多人会想：“嗯，我讨厌数学”或者“我数学不太好”，但你如何区分
between those feelings and true math anxiety? Yeah, that's a great question because you're right. A lot of people say that they do not like math, is their least favorite subject, things like that. But having math anxiety does go much more beyond just that general feeling than just that general feeling of dislike to an actual fear-based reaction. While math, anxiety is not a clinically diagnosable form of anxiety, it does have a lot of the same characteristics and symptoms and behaviors that other forms of anxiety have. So things like negative self-talk, you know, saying bad things to yourself in your head. I can't do this. I'm not smart enough. Racing heart, sweating, brain fog, all of those kinds of things, just like you get with other
这些感受与真正的数学焦虑？是的，这是一个很好的问题，因为你说得对。很多人说他们不喜欢数学，这是他们最讨厌的科目，诸如此类。但患有数学焦虑所带来的影响，远远超出了那种仅仅是不喜欢的一般感觉，它会演变成一种基于恐惧的真实反应。虽然数学焦虑并非临床上可诊断的焦虑症，但它确实具备其他类型焦虑症的许多相同特征、症状和行为。比如消极的自我对话，你知道的，在脑海里对自己说一些糟糕的话：“我做不到”、“我不够聪明”。心跳加速、出汗、大脑一片空白，所有这些症状——就像你在其他
types of anxiety are also present in math anxiety. It's just, it just occurs when people are exposed to thinking about doing math or actually doing math. And so if somebody is like, oh, I don't like math, that's a general dislike. But if someone is like, I can't think, I avoid math, I just don't turn in my assignments, I get so sweaty and nervous when I have to do math, that is probably more likely than just a general dislike is an actual math anxiety issue. So let's talk about what causes it. Does it usually start when kids are struggling with math in school? And can it be possible to be good at math and still have math anxiety?
类型的焦虑中体验到的一样——在数学焦虑中也同样存在。它只是在人们接触到“思考做数学题”或“实际做数学题”时才会出现。因此，如果有人说“哦，我不喜欢数学”，这只是一种普遍的不喜欢；但如果有人说“我脑子转不动”、“我逃避数学”、“我干脆不交作业”、“一想到要做数学题我就出汗、紧张”，这可能就不仅仅是不喜欢了，而是真正的数学焦虑问题。那么，我们来谈谈它的成因。它通常是从孩子们在学校里数学学得吃力时开始的吗？一个人有没有可能数学很好，却依然患有数学焦虑？
There's a lot of discussion and lack of clarity around why some people become math anxious and some people don't. In my own research, one thing that I found is that oftentimes, people will have some type of embarrassing or personally painful experience around math. For instance, I'm in elementary school having to go to the board and complete problems in front of your classmates, getting in trouble for a grade that you received on an exam, feeling a sense of rush or pressure with timed math tasks. So in my own research, that's one place that I find that it comes from. It also can come from our environment.
关于为什么有些人会产生数学焦虑而有些人不会，目前有很多讨论，但并没有明确的定论。在我自己的研究中，我发现的一点是，通常情况下，人们在数学方面经历过某种尴尬或个人痛苦的经历。例如，在小学里，不得不走到黑板前在同学面前解题，因为考试成绩不好而惹上麻烦，或者在限时数学任务中感到慌乱和压力。所以在我的研究中，这就是我发现它产生的一个来源。它也可能源于我们的环境。
So if kids are surrounded by people who make negative comments about mathematics, who make comments about their own ability and math, or use, I'm sorry, have teachers that use very authoritarian teaching techniques, you know, have a lot of rules, don't allow for mistakes, those kinds of things can happen and kind of help people develop math anxiety. For other people, though, it doesn't really happen until middle school or junior high school when the math starts to become a lot more abstract than it was in elementary school. So in middle school or junior high school, you know, you're starting to do things maybe with
因此，如果孩子们周围都是那些对数学发表负面评论的人、对他们在数学方面的能力评头论足的人，或者——抱歉——遇到使用非常专威压式的教学技术的老师，你知道的，规矩很多、不允许犯错，这类情况的发生会在一定程度上帮助人们发展出数学焦虑。然而，对另一些人来说，直到他们升入初中或初级中学，数学开始变得比小学时抽象得多时，这种焦虑才真正出现。所以在初中阶段，你知道的，你开始以更高级的方式接触几何或代数。有时，那些更具抽象性、更具挑战性的
geometry or algebra in more advanced ways. And sometimes that, those more abstract, challenge. kinds of things can make students feel anxious about math. And you can absolutely be good at math and still have math anxiety. We sometimes say, I don't know if you've heard this before, but in psychology, we don't do research. We do me search. And so that's how I actually got interested in math anxiety is I had almost debilitating math anxiety. From the time I was in elementary school, I would pretend to be sick on days that we had a math test.
内容会开始让学生对数学感到焦虑。你完全可以数学很好，但同时又患有数学焦虑。我们有时会说——我不知道你以前听没听说过——在心理学中，我们不做“研究”（research），我们做“我究”（me search）。这就是我如何对数学焦虑产生兴趣的，因为我曾经患有几乎让人虚弱的数学焦虑。从上小学开始，每到有数学考试的日子，我就会假装生病。
I would often, you know, need to sharpen my pencil or go to the nurse's office or go to the bathroom or things like that. And when I was in my doctoral program trying to figure out what I was really interested and passionate about, I remembered those experiences. And I kind of was curious, well, how did I get good grades in math? Right? I always got good grades. I minored in statistics in college and in graduate school. But I have terrible math anxiety. And that's because oftentimes people with math anxiety have the foundational knowledge that they need.
我经常需要去削铅笔、去护士办公室、去洗当我读博士期间，试图弄清楚自己真正感兴趣和热爱的是什么时，我想起了那些经历。我当时很好奇：“嗯，我数学成绩怎么总是那么好呢？”没错，我总是得高分。我在大学和研究生阶段都辅修了统计学。但我有严重的数学焦虑。那是因为通常患有数学焦虑的人拥有他们所需的基石知识，
It's just that that anxiety blocks their ability to find the information that they need. So if you have anxiety and you're saying bad negative thoughts to yourself, like, I'm not smart enough, those thoughts are taking up space in your brain that you could otherwise be using to calculate the math problem. but because our brains only have so much space, calculating the math problem can't also fit in our brains if our brain is full of negative self-talk or worry or things like that. Now, that doesn't necessarily mean that everyone with math anxiety is also good at math, right? There are absolutely people who have high math anxiety and it really affects their performance and it really affects their grades. And sometimes if math anxiety starts early, students will miss.
只是这种焦虑阻断了他们寻找所需信息的能力。因此，如果你感到焦虑，并且对自己说消极的负面想法，比如“我不够聪明”，这些想法就会占用你大脑中的空间，而这些空间本来可以用来计算数学题。但由于我们的大脑容量有限，如果大脑里塞满了消极的自我对话、担忧或类似的事情，计算数学题的空间就无法容纳进去了。现在，这并不一定意味着每个患有数学焦虑的人也都擅长数学，对吧？绝对有这样的人，他们有着高度的数学焦虑，这真的会影响他们的表现和成绩。有时，如果数学焦虑出现得很早，学生就会错过
out on some of those foundational skills that then just exacerbate as they move throughout math and throughout school because they didn't get the foundational information because of their math anxiety, it does get harder and harder. And then they do lack knowledge. So a lot of it depends on the individual person and those individual differences about people. And this is not the same as people who really have debilitating inability to understand math. I mean, that's a completely different syndrome, right? Correct. Yes. There are learning disabilities that are specific to mathematics like discalculia or disnumeria. And that's an actual inability to understand and comprehend
一些基础技能，随着他们在数学和学校学习中的深入，这些基础技能的缺失会进一步恶化。由于数学焦虑导致他们没有掌握基础信息，学习就会变得越来越难。然后他们确实会缺乏知识。因此，这很大程度上取决于个人以及人与人之间的个体差异。这与那些真正对理解数学有严重不能力的人不同，我的意思是，那是完全不同的综合征，对吗？没错。是的。有些学习障碍是针对数学特定方面的，比如计算障碍（dyscalculia）或数字处理障碍（dysnumeria）。这是一种真正无法理解和领会
mathematical relationships and mathematical problem solving. People with math anxiety, may have discalculia or dysnumeria, but they also might not, right? So I, for instance, do not. I don't have a problem understanding and comprehending mathematical problems or what a number means. I just get really stressed out and feel so much pressure that it's hard for my brain to clearly think. Every day, we're in a silent battle with our devices, devices that are slowing and stealthily draining us. Our biology is changing to meet the demands of the information age, but why? And what can we do about it? If you're interested in finding the answers to these questions and more, you have to listen to the Body Electric podcast on NPR. I know that I, like many of us, spend too much time on my phone or scrolling on my tablet when I can be doing other things that could make me healthy and happy.
数学关系及数学问题解决能力的情况。患有数学焦虑的人，可能伴有计算障碍或数字处理障碍，但也可能没有，对吧？所以，比如我本人就没有。我在理解和领会数学问题或数字含义方面没有任何问题。我只是变得非常紧张，承受着巨大的压力，以至于我的大脑很难清晰地思考。每天，我们都在与我们的设备进行着一场无声的战役，这些设备正在悄无声息、偷偷摸摸地消耗着我们。我们的生理机能正在发生变化，以适应信息时代的需求，但为什么会这样？我们又能对此做些什么呢？如果你有兴趣寻找这些问题的答案以及更多内容，你必须听听NPR的“身体电力”（Body Electric）播客。我知道我——就像我们中的许多人一样——花在手机上的时间太多了，或者当我可以去做其他能让我保持健康和快乐的事情时，却一直在平板电脑上刷个不停。
Body Electric is an interactive six-part series that investigates how our relationship with technology is affecting our health. From near-sightedness to mass psychogenic illnesses to type 2 diabetes rates doubling in young people, Body Electric is partnering with Columbia Medical School to find out why and how these changes are happening and what we can do about them. Body Electric offers tips for parents, debunks popular myths, and provides solutions you can take part in. With the mounting pressures of today's society, Body Electric strives to help lighten your load mentally and physically. Listen now to Body Electric on TED Radio Hour from NPR wherever you get your podcasts. Can it hit later? I mean, you talked about experiencing it in college and graduate school,
“身体电力”是一个互动的六集系列节目，旨在调查我们与科技的关系如何影响我们的健康。从近视到大众心因性疾病，再到年轻人群中的2型糖尿病发病率翻倍，“身体电力”正与哥伦比亚医学院合作，以找出这些变化发生的原因和方式，以及我们能对此做些什么。“身体电力”为父母提供了建议，揭穿了流行的神话，并提供了你可以参与的解决方案。随着当今社会压力的不断增加，“身体电力”致力于在精神和身体上帮助你减轻负担。赶快通过NPR的TED广播节目（TED Radio Hour），在您获取播客的任何地方收听“身体电力”吧。它会晚些时候才发作吗？我的意思是，你谈到了在大学和研究生院经历过它，
but could you like go along and be kind of okay with math and then? and all of a sudden you're in grad school and you get hit with statistics or differential equations and it's like, oh, I don't get this. Now what? Yeah, absolutely. While we tend to think that most people probably do experience it sometime in the K-12 environment, it's absolutely possible that college or graduate school or even a professional setting might be a person's first exposure to certain kinds of math that arouse that anxiety. And so there's actually a whole other research line that's related to statistics anxiety, because statistics are a little different than math, right? And so sometimes people who have math anxiety will also have statistics anxiety. Sometimes they don't. But we do often find that even in
但你有没有可能一路走来，对数学还算应付得过去，然后突然之间，你上了研究生院，遭遇了统计学或微分方程，然后就觉得：“哦，我看不懂这个。现在怎么办？”是的，绝对有可能。虽然我们倾向于认为大多数人可能是在K-12（幼儿园到高中）教育阶段的某个时候经历过这种焦虑，但完全有可能的是，大学、研究生院甚至职业环境，才是一个人首次接触到会引发这种焦虑的特定数学。因此，实际上还有另一整条与“统计学焦虑”相关的研究路线，因为统计学与数学有点不同，对吧？所以有时患有数学焦虑的人也会有统计学焦虑。有时他们没有。但我们经常发现，即使在
graduate students across lots of different disciplines and fields, that if those graduate students do have some kind of math anxiety, they often delay taking their statistics and research methods courses until the end. A lot of times college students will do the same thing. If they experience a math course that they really struggled in or that they arouse their anxiety, they'll put it off. Maybe they'll drop the class. And they might have said, oh, I've always been fine with math. I actually had an NSF grant from the National Science Foundation with some of my colleagues who are Earth scientists or geoscientist. And we did a study where we did interventions in an introductory STEM class to try to help especially female students, but really all students, have better kind of
许多不同学科和领域的众多研究生中，如果这些研究生确实患有某种数学焦虑，他们通常会将统计学和研究方法课程拖延到最后才学。很多时候，大学生也会这样做。如果他们遇到一门让他们感到非常吃力或引发焦虑的数学课程，他们就会把它推迟。也许他们会退掉这门课。他们可能还会说：“哦，我一直觉得数学挺好的。”我实际上曾从国家科学基金会（National Science Foundation）获得过一项NSF资助，合作者是我的一些身为地球科学家或地质科学家的同事。我们做了一项研究，在初级STEM（科学、技术、工程、数学）课程中进行干预，试图帮助特别是女学生，但实际上是所有学生，建立更好的一种
just overall attitudes towards math that include lower math anxiety, increased self-confidence, having more motivation and interest towards math. And we found really, really interesting things. in especially some of our qualitative analyses, we found that there were a number of people who reported not ever really experiencing negative math attitudes or having negative math experiences until they got to college. And then when they got to college and they were, like you said, doing differential equations or someone's like,
整体对数学的态度，其中包括降低数学焦虑、增强自信心，以及对数学有更多的动机和兴趣。我们发现了非常非常有趣的事情。特别是在我们的一些定性分析中，我们发现有相当一部分人报告说，在进入大学之前，他们从没有真正经历过消极的数学态度或糟糕的数学经历。然后当他们进入大学，就像你说的，他们正在做微分方程，或者有人对他们说：
compute this within subjects variance for this anova, right, that stresses them out. And it's really the first time that they've had that kind of exposure and experience with math that made them feel a certain way. And then that kind of exacerbates, right? So if I'm a college freshman and I'm having my first experience with math anxiety, I'm probably not rushing out to take another math class. Or I'm probably not majoring in accounting or physics, you know. And so whether it develops when you're young in the K-12 or in college or graduate school, It does tend to have negative outcomes in terms of the choices that you make and the kinds of things that you expose yourself to.
“为这个方差分析（ANOVA）计算组内方差”，对吧，这让他们感到压力山大。这确实是他们第一次接触到这种数学并有这样的体验，从而让他们产生了一种特定的情绪。然后这种情绪就会恶化，对吧？因此，如果我是一个大学大一新生，并且我第一次体验到了数学焦虑，我可能不会急着去选修另一门数学课。或者我可能不会主修会计或物理，你知道的。因此，无论它是在你年轻时的K-12阶段发展出来的，还是在大学或研究生院发展出来的，它往往会在你做出的选择以及你让自己接触的事物类型方面带来负面结果。
And that leads me to the question of what happens to people with math anxiety as adults. I mean, yes, there could be career choices that you make as a result of wanting to avoid math. But what about in the rest of your life? Yeah. So in addition to those career choices, there's also things like, you know, I think a lot of times people don't recognize and realize how much math is actually in our lives. So I recently purchased a new area rug for my bedroom. And that's math, right?
这就引出了我的问题：患有数学焦虑的人在成年后会怎么样？我的意思是，是的，你可能会因为想避开数学而做出某种职业选择。但在你生活的其他方面呢？是的。所以，除了这些职业选择之外，还有一些事情，比如——我觉得很多时候人们并没有意识到数学在我们的生活中究竟占了多大比重。我最近为我的卧室买了一块新的小面积地毯。这就是数学，对吧？
I had to figure out which size of the area rug is going to fit in my bedroom. So I had to measure my bedroom and figure out how much space around the rug I wanted and all of that, right? As someone with math anxiety, that absolutely is. nerve-wracking for me. So often what I do is I use a heuristic. Instead of actually measuring, I estimate, right? So I, for instance, am approximately six feet tall. And so then I visualize how many of Molly could lay on this floor. And then I say, okay, well, that's about one and a half Mollies, so I'm going to go with nine feet, right? And sometimes it's okay. Like my area
我必须弄清楚哪个尺寸的地毯才适合我的卧室。所以我必须测量我的卧室，算出我希望地毯周围留出多少空间，诸如此类，对吧？作为一个患有数学焦虑的人，这对我来说绝对是伤脑筋的。所以我经常做的是使用一种启发式方法。我不去实际测量，而是进行估算，对吧？所以，举个例子，我身高大约六英尺。然后我就在脑海里想象有多少个“莫莉”可以躺在这个地板上。然后我说：“好吧，那大约是一点五个莫莉，所以我决定买九英尺的。”有时候结果还行。比如我估算的那块地毯
around that I estimated fit just fine. But other times it doesn't work so well, right? Like when you actually need to measure something or you need to do your taxes or you need to calculate a tip or any of those kinds of things are going to require math. And it's not very good to estimate on your taxes, right? You want that actual, like, precise calculation. And for people with math anxiety, that can be really stressful. And so they can avoid things like that. I know of people who have avoided doing their taxes because of their math anxiety. Another big thing about being an adult and having math anxiety is if you are a parent, that math anxiety will very likely be modeled for your children, even if you don't mean for it to be modeled to your children, it's really hard sometimes
铺在周围刚刚好。但有时却不管用，对吧？比如当你真的需要测量某样东西，或者你需要报税，或者你需要计算小费时，所有这些事情都需要用到数学。在报税时估算可不太好，对吧？你需要那种实际的、精确的计算。对于患有数学焦虑的人来说，这可能会压力巨大。因此他们会避开这类事情。我认识一些人，他们因为数学焦虑而一直逃避报税。作为成年人拥有数学焦虑的另一个大问题是，如果你是父母，这种数学焦虑很可能会潜移默化地影响你的孩子，即使你并非有意在孩子面前表现出这种焦虑。有时候，当你患有数学焦虑时，要做到不发表消极评论真的很难，对吧？或者不脱口而出这样的话：“哦，去找你另一个家长吧。我数学就是不好，对吧？”诸如此类。因此，孩子们会捕捉到这些信息，并认为：“哦，数学不适合我”或者“我本来就该害怕数学”或者“我跟我妈一样，她有数学焦虑，所以我肯定也有。”因此，作为一个成年人，除了在这些日常生活中影响你自己的生活之外，它还会向下渗透并影响你的孩子和家庭，让他们将这些对自己不利的信念内化。那么，你对那些正试图将此作为一个问题来处理的教育工作者有什么建议呢？他们究竟该如何在学生身上识别数学焦虑？有没有什么测试可以让他们进行，以确保
when you have math anxiety to not make a negative comment, right? Or to not say something like, oh, go ask your other parent. I'm just not good at math, right? Things like that. And so kids pick up on those messages and they learn like, oh, math isn't for me or I'm supposed to be scared of math or I'm just like my mom and she has math anxiety. And so I must have it as well. And so as an adult, in addition to affecting your own life in these like day to day kinds of ways, it can also trickle down and affect your children and your family and have them internalizing those beliefs about themselves. So what do you say to educators who are trying to deal with this as a problem? How can they really recognize math anxiety in their students? Is there some kind of a test that they can run to make
这不仅仅是一个不喜欢数学的孩子，而是一个真正焦虑的孩子？是的，绝对有。所以在播客开始时你提到了我的量表。它被称为“儿童焦虑与数学量表”（Children's Anxiety and Math Scale）。你可以给我发邮件，我很乐意与任何人分享一份副本——无论是K-12教育工作者、研究人员，还是任何对这个量表感兴趣的人。它非常容易实施，也非常好评分。它能让你对学生根据回答问题的情况是否可能患有数学焦虑有一个总体了解，对吧？另一件事是，如果你没有时间或能力去做这样直接的测量，我给K-12老师的另一个建议是与学校心理学家合作并进行沟通。
sure that it's not just a kid who doesn't like math, but this is really an anxious child? Yeah, absolutely. So you mentioned my scale at the beginning of the podcast. It's called the Children's Anxiety and Math Scale. You can email me and I will gladly share a copy with anyone, K through 12, educator, researchers, anyone who's interested in the scale, it's very easy to administer and it's very easy to score. And it kind of just gives you an overall idea if the student is likely to have math anxiety based on how they're answering questions, right? The other thing, if you don't have the time or ability to do a direct measure like that, another thing I would recommend to K-12 teachers is to work with and talk to your school psychologist.
因为如果你没有时间和能力亲自评估，学校心理学家将能够进行一些评估。我曾与许多学校心理学家合作过，他们在K-12教育环境中使用了我的量表来帮助孩子们。我还要说的是，如果你是一名K-12教育工作者，或者在K-12环境中工作，请观察孩子们在数学课上时都在做些什么。逃避是孩子们非常普遍的一种行为。
Because your school psychologist will be able to do some assessments if you don't have the time and ability to do that. I've worked with a number of school psychologists who've used my scale to work with kids in K-12 settings. I would also say if you're a K-12 educator or work in a K-12 setting, watch what your kids do when it's time for math. That's a very common thing for kids is avoidance. when it's time for math, they might, like I said earlier, you know, I would have to go to the restroom or I'd be sick or I need to sharpen my pencil. And if you have some kids who are constantly doing that and it's always around math, then there's a possibility that they might have math anxiety. The other thing that you want to really look for is how they are performing in math compared to other subjects. Right. So if they have generally high grade, grades and other things, but their math grade is out of proportion low, that could be a sign that, well, you first would want to check, obviously, for discalculia or dysnumeria, but then if like a school psychologist rules those out, it's very probable that math anxiety could be the reason that
当该上数学课时，他们可能会——就像我刚才说的——“我得去洗手间”、“我生病了”或者“我需要去削铅笔”。如果你发现有些孩子经常这样做，而且总是在数学课前后，那么他们就有可能患有数学焦虑。你需要真正留意的另一件事是，他们在数学上的表现与其他科目相比如何。对吧。如果他们在其他学科上通常成绩很好，但他们的数学成绩低得不成比例，这可能是一个迹象——当然，你首先会想要排查他们是否有计算障碍或数字处理障碍，但如果学校心理学家排除了这些，数学焦虑极有可能是导致
that kid is scoring at a lower level compared to their other things. So there has been a long time stereotype that girls aren't as good at math as boys. Are girls more likely to experience math anxiety? How is this tied into societal stereotypes about girls and women? This was actually one of the first things that kind of drew me into math anxiety research was recognizing that this does seem to be an issue that affects. women more than men, despite decades of research showing that math ability and math performance between girls and boys or between women and men is really non-existent, right? There are tiny little
这个孩子在数学上得分较低、而其他科目表现正常的原因。长期以来一直存在一种刻板印象，认为女孩的数学不如男孩好。女孩比男孩更容易经历数学焦虑吗？这与关于女孩和女性的社会刻板印象是如何联系在一起的？这实际上是最初吸引我进入数学焦虑研究的领域之一：我意识到，尽管数十年来有研究表明女孩和男孩之间、或者女性和男性之间的数学能力和数学表现实际上并不存在差异，但这似乎仍然是一个对女性的影响大于男性的问题，对吧？存在微小的
differences, but across the board, girls and boys and women and men have the same propensity for math skills. There's not really a gender issue with math, despite that stereotype. But when it comes to math anxiety, there are absolutely gender differences. And it does likely come from, what's the word? Internalizing. It likely comes from women internalizing that societal stereotype, right? So as a woman, if I say, oh, society says women aren't good at math and I'm a woman, I must not be good at math. And I start kind of thinking about that potential for stereotype threat, right, where there's a stereotype about me or my group and because of that stereotype, I get anxious and then perform as the stereotype says, right? And so that happens with women in math. And so because they've
差异，但总体而言，女孩和男孩、女性和男性对数学技能的倾向是一样的。尽管有这种刻板印象，但数学并不存在真正的性别问题。然而，当谈到数学焦虑时，绝对存在性别差异。这很可能源于——用哪个词呢？——内化。它很可能是由于女性内化了那种社会刻板印象，对吧？因此，作为一名女性，如果我说：“哦，社会说女性数学不好，而我是一个女性，那我数学一定不好。”然后我开始思考这种“刻板印象威胁”（stereotype threat）的可能性，对吧？也就是说，存在一个针对我或我所属群体的刻板印象，正因为这个刻板印象，我感到了焦虑，然后表现得正如刻板印象所说的那样，对吧？女性在数学上就会发生这种情况。因此，因为她们内化了这种刻板印象，因为存在着证实这种刻板印象的担忧和恐惧，我认为女性对数学确实感到更加焦虑。我们在自我报告中也看到了这一点，
internalized that stereotype, because there's a worry and a fear of confirming the stereotype, I think that women do get more anxious about math. And we see this both in self-report, So when we're doing like a survey and we ask people, how math anxious are you? We see gender differences with women reporting higher levels of math anxiety. But we also see it in implicit measures of math anxiety. So there's a great study by a colleague of mine, Orly Rubinstein. And she gave people like a reaction time implicit measure test with words that had to do with math and it had to do with different genders. and found that women would report even implicitly more negative emotions and negative reactions
所以当我们进行问卷调查并询问人们“你的数学焦虑程度有多高”时，我们看到了性别差异，女性报告的数学焦虑水平更高。但我们在数学焦虑的内隐测量中也看到了这一点。我的同事奥莉·鲁宾斯坦（Orly Rubinstein）做过一项非常棒的研究。她让人们参加一项反应时间的内隐测量测试，其中包含与数学相关的词语以及与不同性别相关的词语。
in response to words that had to do with math. Those kinds of measures, like implicit measures of anxiety, the stimulus being presented to people happened so fast that there's not time for like conscious awareness. right? So no woman is looking at the computer screen and has time to say, oh, that screen says math. I don't like math. I'm going to push this button. It's not a thoughtful process like that with implicit measures. It's supposed to happen very quick. A word is flashed on the screen and the participant has to push a button on the computer. That research also shows that women have higher levels of math anxiety, that they're slower to respond to math words, that they're avoidant when it comes
研究发现，女性甚至在内隐层面上，对与数学相关的词语也会表现出更多消极的情绪和消极的反应。这类测量，比如焦虑的内隐测量，呈现给人们的刺激发生得太快了，以至于没有时间进行有意识的觉察，对吧？所以没有哪个女性在看着电脑屏幕时有时间说：“哦，那个屏幕上写着数学。我不喜欢数学。我要按下这个按钮。”对于内隐测量来说，这不是一个深思熟虑的过程。它应该发生得非常快。一个词在屏幕上闪现，参与者必须按下电脑上的一个按钮。这项研究还表明，女性具有更高水平的数学焦虑，她们对数学词语的反应更慢，在面对数学词语时具有逃避倾向。因此，尽管真正的刻板印象并不是真的，即数学能力并不存在性别差异，但这种内化绝对导致了女性的数学焦虑水平高于男性。你知道数学焦虑有多常见吗？周围有这方面的数据吗？是的，有一些数据，但根据你所关注的人群不同，跨度非常大。但通常的数字大约是：大约25%的本科生经历了某种程度的数学焦虑，这对其表现、表现或学习产生了负面影响。
to math words. So even though the actual stereotype is not true, that there are not gender differences in math ability, that internalization has absolutely resulted in women having higher levels of math anxiety than men do. Do you have any idea how common math anxiety is? Is there data around that? Yeah, there is some data, but it's a very big range depending on the population of people that you are looking at. But typically the numbers are around like 25% of undergraduate students experience some level of math anxiety that negatively impacts their performance, their performance or their learning.
其他研究提到，在一般人群中，或者在社区学院或两年制大学中，这一比例高达80%，这些群体中的数学焦虑发生率通常更高。但这是一个很大的范围，对吧？从25%的人到80%的人。所以它确实在很大程度上取决于你调查的是谁。但在我的大部分研究中，我倾向于说，至少四分之一的本科生患有数学焦虑，这可能是一个相当不错的估计数字。
Other research has talked about it being up to 80% of people like in the general population or at community colleges or two-year colleges that there are often higher rates of math anxiety in those groups. But that's a very big range, right? 25% of people to 80% of people. So it really does depend a lot on who you're looking at. But in most of my work, I tend to say that it's at least one and four undergraduate students. It's probably a pretty good estimate of the number of people who have math anxiety.
那么，对于那些有数学焦虑症孩子的父母，你有什么建议？他们可以去哪里寻求帮助？所以我想说，最重要的事情之一——我自己也是一位家长——当我的女儿出生时，我必须做的第一件事之一，就是对自己如何谈论数学、如何谈论自己以及自己的能力保持高度的正念。我知道，如果我对她说这样的话：“哦，去找你爸爸吧，因为我其实不太确定怎么做这个。”
So what advice do you have for parents who have children with math anxiety? Where can they go to get help? So I would say one of the biggest things to do, and I'm a parent myself. And so one of the first things I had to kind of do when my daughter was born was be very mindful just of how I talk about math and how I talk about myself and my own abilities. And I knew that if I said things to her like, you know, go ask your dad because I'm not really sure how to do this. that that was sending certain messages. And I had to do this as an educational psychologist who researches this. I had to be very intentional about reminding myself.
这就会传递出某些信息。而我必须作为一个研究这个课题的教育心理学家来做到这一点。我必须非常刻意地提醒自己。因此，如果你是一位家长，并且你有数学焦虑，请对你所说的话保持高度的正念。如果你需要把写着关于数学的积极事情的小便签贴在墙上，以便提醒自己去说，比如：“数学是有趣的问题解决。”或者：“哇，我们必须非常努力，看看我们取得了多大的成功。”就像把这些便签贴在周围一样。这样你就有一句可以替代的话可说，而不是你最先想说的话——作为一个对数学感到焦虑的人，你最先想说的话可能不会是什么积极的内容。第二件事是，帮助
So if you're a parent and you have math anxiety, be really mindful about what you're saying. If you need to put little sticky notes up on the wall with positive things about math that you can remind yourself to say, like, math is fun problem solving. Or, wow, we have to work so. hard and look at how much we succeed. But like putting those sticky notes around. So you have an alternative thing to say as opposed to your your first thing that you want to say, which as a math anxious person is probably not something positive. The second thing is a really important way to help
数学焦虑患者的一个极其重要的方法，是为他们提供在数学上获得成功的机会，从而建立他们的自信。在我自己的研究中，我一次又一次地发现，自我效能感（self-efficacy）——即一个人对自己有能力在特定任务中成功的信心——对于数学焦虑是否会影响人们的表现至关重要。这就是为什么我，例如，是一个这样的人：尽管我有数学焦虑，我在数学上表现得还不错，也取得了很好的成绩，因为我对自己的学习能力充满信心。我对自己的表现充满信心，即使事情变得艰难时也是如此。因此，帮助你的孩子建立这种自我效能感是非常非常重要的。这样一来，即使他们感到焦虑，自我效能感也会起到一种保护因素的作用，
people with math anxiety is to give them opportunities for success with math so that that can build their confidence. In my own research, I find over and over and over that self-efficacy or a person's confidence in their ability to succeed in a specific task, that is critical for whether or not math anxiety affects people's performance. And that's why I, for example, am someone who, even though I had math anxiety, I did okay in math and I got good grades because I have a lot of confidence in my ability to learn. And I have a lot of confidence in my ability to perform well, even when things are hard. So helping your kids build that self-efficacy is really, really important. And that way, even if they have anxiety, the self-efficacy kind of serves as a protective factor.
焦虑就不会必然影响他们的表现。那么，你如何建立效能感呢？好吧，就像我说的，提供成功的机会。这是建立自信的一个好方法。让一个人看到他们能够做到，这是非常重要的。有时这意味着对于患有数学焦虑的孩子，我们可能需要给他们一些符合他们水平的题目或数学作业，对吧？或者可能稍微低于他们的水平一点，这样他们就能获得成功的机会。一旦他们开始觉得自己有能力获得成功，他们就会付出努力、尝试、提出问题并坚持下去。因此，真正建立这种自信我认为是关键所在。
And the anxiety doesn't necessarily impact their performance. So how do you build efficacy? Right. Well, like I said, opportunities for success. That's a great way. to build confidence. Letting someone see that they can do it is so important. And sometimes this means with kids and math anxiety, we might need to give them some problems or some math work that's at their level, right? Or maybe just a little bit below their level so that they can have those opportunities for success. Once they start to feel like they're capable of success, then they're going to put an effort, they're going to try, they're going to ask questions, and they're going to persist. So really building that confidence is, I think, key.
如果你是家长，向你孩子的学校寻求帮助。再次说明，我必须为学校心理学这个“心理学家族”的成员做个宣传，因为他们在K-12教育环境中做得非常出色，能够提供评估、干预，提供自我效能的建立。为孩子们提供效能建设。因此，我认为与孩子的学校进行合作是让他们获得所需资源的绝佳途径。此外，还有大量免费且唾手可得的优质资源，比如这个播客，
If you're a parent, ask your child's school for help. Again, I have to put a plug in for my psychology sibling of school psychology because they do such a great job in the K-12 settings of providing assessments, providing interventions, providing self-executive. providing, you know, self-efficacy building for kids. So I think that partnering with your child's school is a really great way to get them the resources that they need. And then also there's tons of great resources free and available like this podcast,
比如网站和博客上来自APA的文章。因此，只需在互联网上进行搜索可能会有很大帮助，因为你会找到关于如何帮助孩子的博客和此类信息。在其他学科（例如阅读）中是否存在类似 A 的焦虑，还是说数学焦虑是独一无二的？它只是关于你大脑中受影响的那部分吗？所以数学焦虑往往是被研究得最多的学术学科领域的焦虑。但绝对还有其他与学业相关的焦虑类型。
like articles from APA on websites and blogs. So doing just a search on the internet will probably help a lot because you'll find blogs and information like this about how to help your kids. Do similar anxieties exist in other subjects such as reading or is math anxiety just unique? Is it just about that part of your brain that, you know, is affected? So math anxiety tends to be the most studied of the academic discipline area anxieties. But there's absolutely other kinds of anxiety. related to academics. So there's there is a reading anxiety, foreign language anxiety, computer or
所以存在阅读焦虑、外语焦虑、计算机或技术焦虑。然后我看到一些针对物理和自然科学特定领域的研究，比如化学，经常有很多研究关注化学焦虑。但数学绝对是我认为被研究得最多的。这可能是因为它是一个遭到强烈排斥的领域。你知道的，很多人说他们不喜欢数学。这是他们最不喜欢的科目。所以我认为正因为如此，它让研究人员意识到：“哦，也许这里面还有其他事情在发生。”那么你现在还在研究什么？
technology anxiety. And then I've seen some research done in specific areas of physical and natural sciences like chemistry, often does a lot of research looking at chemistry anxiety. But math is absolutely, I think, the most researched. And it's probably because of It's such a strongly disliked area. You know, so many people say they dislike math. It's their least favorite subject. And so I think because of that, it made researchers realize like, oh, maybe there's something else going on here, too. So what else are you studying now?
你仍在试图解答的重大问题是什么？所以，实际上我对这个感到非常兴奋。我从国家科学基金会（National Science Foundation）获得了另一项NSF资助。我对此超级兴奋——倒不是说我对所有的资助不兴奋，但我对这个超级兴奋，因为它是为了向职前小学教师（pre-service elementary school teachers）提供干预措施。因此，职前小学教师或一般的小学教师往往在所有大学专业中拥有最高的数学焦虑。研究经常表明，他们选择小学教育专业，部分原因是
What are the big questions that you're still trying to answer? So I'm really excited, actually, about this. Another NSF grant that I received from the National Science. Foundation. This one I'm super excited about, not that I'm not excited about all of my grants, but this one I'm super excited about because it is to provide interventions to pre-service elementary school teachers. So pre-service elementary school teachers or elementary school teachers in general tend to have the highest math anxiety of any college major. And often the research shows that they select elementary education, in part because,
因为对数学的要求较低。所以我的团队和决定要做的是，试图在这些职前小学教师的大一数学课堂上开展工作。他们必须修读一门数学内容课程，向他们传授他们有朝一日将教给自己的学生的那种数学内容。我们要进去，对数学焦虑、数学效能感、数学兴趣、数学回避进行前测和后测。在前后测之间的时间段里，他们将接受一系列不同的干预措施。
of the lower math requirements. And so what my team and I decided to do was to try to go into these pre-service elementary teachers' math classrooms in their freshman year. They have to take like a math content class that teaches them about the content of math that they will be teaching to their own students one day. We're going to go in, do pre and post measures of math anxiety, math efficacy, math interests, math avoidance. And in the time period between the pre and the post test, they will get a series of different interventions. I won't say too much just in case any of our participants happen to listen,
我不会说太多，以防我们的任何参与者恰好在听，但他们将获得基于实证的不同干预措施。其目标确实是试图增加他们建设性的数学倾向：通过这些干预措施，减少数学焦虑、增加数学自信、增加数学兴趣、增加数学价值、减少数学回避。这项研究一个非常酷的部分是，我们还使用眼动追踪技术来测量这些职前小学教师在进行与数学相关的任务时的视觉注意力。这样我们不仅可以看到他们是否在自我报告中表现出消极的数学态度，还可以看到他们实际的认知和视觉注意力。我们希望，这将
but they will get different interventions that are evidence-based. And the goal is really to try to increase their productive mathematical dispositions. So decrease math anxiety, increase math confidence, increase math interest, increase math value, decrease math avoidance through these interventions. A really cool part of this study is we're also using eye tracking technology to measure the visual attention of these preservice teachers when they're doing math-related tasks. So that way we can see not only are they maybe self-reporting having negative math, math attitudes, but their actual cognitive and visual attention, what we hope is that that will
同样表明，在数学高度焦虑的职前小学教师中，他们的行为有所不同。他们会避免注视数学。因此我们希望我们的干预措施也能对此有所帮助，以便我们最终能够——你知道的——为全国各地的职前小学教师提供干预措施，从而降低他们的数学焦虑，这样他们走上讲坛时就会不那么焦虑，也许就不太可能向学生们展示这种焦虑。希望他们会更喜欢数学一点。他们的学生也会更喜欢数学一点。
also show that in highly math anxious, pre-service teachers, that they behave differently. They avoid looking at math. And so we hope that our interventions will help that, too, so that we can eventually, you know, provide interventions for pre-service elementary teachers all across the country. so that that will decrease their math anxiety and then they go into the classroom and are less anxious and maybe are less likely to model that anxiety for their students. And hopefully they like math a little better. Their students like math a little better.
所以这就是我目前专注的大项目。它刚刚开始。我对此超级兴奋。但我也在关注其他几个很酷的事情。所以其中一件事是可读性（readability），这与字体在电脑屏幕上呈现或打印出来的方式有关。某些字体比其他字体更具可读性。我们从阅读类研究中对这一点了解很多。
So that's the big project I'm focusing on right now. It just started. I'm super excited about it. But I've also got a couple of other cool things that we're looking at. So one thing is readability, and that has to do with the way that font is presented on a computer screen or when it's printed. And certain fonts are more readable than other fonts. And we know this a lot from, you know, reading kinds of research.
但从来没有人真正研究过它与数学的联系。因此，我的一名博士生、一位同事和我目前正在研究这一点，以观察当它是数学题时，不同类型的字体是否会对一个人的焦虑程度或他们对自己回答问题能力的自信心产生影响。我们认为这尤其相关，因为很多时候，特别是在大学里，数学是在电脑上教的，或者学生会在电脑上做数学作业或数学测验。因此，如果我们因为所使用的字体而引发了他们的焦虑，更改字体以使其更具可读性从而降低人们的焦虑，这是一个非常简单的解决方法。所以这些真的是我
But nobody has ever really looked at it related to math. And so one of my doctoral students, a colleague and I, are looking at that right now to see do different types of fonts when it's a math problem, do those different types of fonts make a difference in how anxious someone is or how confident they feel and their ability to answer the question. We think this is particularly relevant because a lot of times, especially in college, math is taught on a computer or the students will do math homework or math quizzes on a computer. And so if we are arousing their anxiety because of the type of font that's being used, that's a very easy fix to change font to make a more readable to decrease people's anxiety. So those are really like the
目前专注的两件事。不过还有很多小项目。你知道的，我的量表，我喜欢对其进行验证，以确保它在不同的群体和具有不同背景的孩子中仍然能很好地测量数学焦虑。所以我一直在做这件事。但我现在真正感兴趣的是，关于我们如何帮助患有
two things that I'm focusing on right now. Lots of little projects though. You know, my scale and I like to validate and make sure that it's still doing a good job of measuring math anxiety and different populations and kids with different backgrounds. So I'm always doing that. But really interested right now and kind of the application of how we can help people with. with math anxiety. Well, Dr. Jameson, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think the information you put out there is going to be very helpful to a lot of parents and teachers.
数学焦虑的人的这种应用。好的，詹姆森博士，我要感谢你今天加入我的节目。我认为你分享的信息将对许多家长和老师非常有帮助。
Well, good. Thank you so much for having me. You can read more about psychologists' research on math anxiety in the October issue of APA's magazine, Monitor on Psychology. Go to www.apa.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your favorite podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review.
很好，谢谢你邀请我。你可以通过阅读美国心理协会《心理学观察》杂志10月号，了解更多关于心理学家对数学焦虑的研究。访问www.apa.org/monitor。你可以在speakingofpsychology.org网站，或者在Apple、Spotify、YouTube以及你获取喜爱的播客的任何地方收听《心理学心声》往期节目。如果你喜欢我们的节目，请订阅并给我们留个评价。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学心声》由Lee Wynerman制作。我们的音响编辑是Chris Condyenne。谢谢收听。我是Kim Mills，代表美国心理协会。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。